in a little over a month the PSP's
PlayStation Store will be removed in
North America this follows its removal
in other regions including Europe back
in 2014
you will still be able to purchase
content for your handheld device from
the PlayStation Store website which you
can then access from the download hub on
your PSP but you will not be able to
make purchases directly from the PSP
store you will also still be able to
make in-game purchases after the
shutdown Sony did not provide an
explanation as to why the PSP store is
getting axed this isn't the only thing
that Sony is pulling the plug on the
PlayStation TV has been discontinued in
the US and Europe shipments for the
device stopped at the end of 2015
once again Sony did not provide a reason
for this decision the PlayStation TV
launched in 2014 at $99 MSRP since its
release the micro console has suffered
numerous price cuts you can now buy the
system for $50 on Amazon but it's not
all bad news coming out of Sony today it
sounds like we could be getting another
Uncharted beta this weekend but Sony has
not confirmed this yet for more news
stay tuned to game spot